what does a pristine island nation do to  protect the environment when its primary  economic driver is tourism Palau a  nation of small islands in the western  Pacific Ocean is making big waves when  it comes to sustainability the nation is  the first in the world to launch an  eco-tourism pledge that is required upon  entry the passport stamp reads children  of Palau I take this pledge as your  guest to preserve and protect your  beautiful and unique island home I vowed  to tread lightly act kindly and explore  mindfully I shall not take what is not  given  I shall not harm what does not harm me  the only footprints I shall leave are  those that will wash away now what if  every country required such a pledge to  protect its environment and culture for  future generations  [Music]